hey guys ijustine here that's me i just
got back from comic-con this weekend now
let me just tell you what for those of
you that don't know what comic-con is
the only real way to explain to somebody
who has no idea what it is is it's kind
of like the whole city of san diego
turns into halloween for an entire
weekend there's fun panels there's fun
people everyone is pretty much dressed
up in a costume there's even a zombie
walk they're not attacking us because i
bathed in zombie club that's where we
got here oh it's just silly yeah
somebody doesn't watch walking dead
here's some clips of some things that i
did over the weekend hope you enjoy
all right we're here at comic con 2011.
get ready
i don't even tell you to get ready for
because i don't even know what's gonna
happen today
amazing
the legos
i can't imagine sitting there building
one of these but i really want to look
at this this is so sweet
i want this kit
i want to build this in my apartment
oh my god
my eyes are watering
you are crying
i am why i love muffins
he's definitely
calling someone but he doesn't know who
to call
you me and jen i'm gonna get mario luigi
backpacks
i'm gonna put so much stuff in there do
you want to be mario or do you want to
lose i know that you like mario
i do like mario and you're taller than
me so i feel like you should be luis
yeah that makes complete sense complete
sense with our backpacks there's hats we
can't decide about this hat but this hat
oh my god you look nice you look twice
as tall look ready ready
so i'm hoping they have some snacks over
there
the mass effect 3 demo at comic con in
2011 let me tell you what my birthday is
in march until you're my birthday
present
oh hold on let me have it here and
happy birthday to me i'm gonna get
myself mass effect
hey all right so we're hanging out here
at comic-con now diane hi everyone
you're the vp of pop chips vp of pop
culture pop culture i get to go to pop
culture events and cover them for pop
ships and just really
meet a ton of cool people yeah
really hard it's okay
i don't have my lens on though yeah
mine's a little more scratched up
because you're a hardcore blogger
i just like throw mine in my purse
gas my ass
what
hope you guys enjoyed the clips from
comic con for those of you who have been
to comic con before what's your favorite
thing and for those of you who have
never been to comic-con before how many
times did i say comic-con in this video
i don't know all right that's it don't
forget to subscribe check out the rest
of my youtube channels and i'll see you
guys in the next video bye
hey guys i just seen here hi
no hate